we have had another national holiday and
another complete and total faux pas
disaster from the Trump administration
this was vice president Mike Pence who
you might recall refers to his mom as
mother and won't go places without a
chaperone if he's with women other than
his wife Mike Pence our buddy
likened Donald Trump to Martin Luther
King jr. in an interview on television
of the day before Martin Luther King Day
2019 a quick note we did do a new show
on Martin Luther King Day this year
people very very angry when we don't and
we did it because the holiday schedule
at the end of the year ended up with a
bunch of days off we felt let's do a
show because we've been off a lot so I
will tell you that in 2020 we probably
won't be doing a show on Martin Luther
King Day but back to our story Mike
Pence interviewed on CBS's Face the
Nation he's pressed about the latest
Trump proposal to end the government
shutdown with funding for the border
wall and pence out of nowhere comes in
and compares or likens Donald Trump to
Martin Luther King surprising not just
everybody on the set but a majority of
the country and the world as well that's
not really a comparison most people
would think to make but alas here is
Mike Pence making it bring together the
Democrats priorities to accomplish that
that's what the American people expect
us to do and honestly you know you know
the hearts and minds of the American
people today are thinking a lot about it
being the weekend where we remember the
life and work of the Reverend dr. Martin
Luther King jr. but one of my favorite
quotes from dr. King was now is the time
to make real the promises of democracy
you think of how he changed America he
inspired us to change through the
legislative process to become a more
perfect union that's exactly what
President Trump is calling on the
Congress to do and come to the table in
a spirit of good faith what's
particularly infuriating to me about all
of these right-wingers now acting like
Martin Luther King was just the best and
Trump's like him and were remembering
Martin Luther King that a lot of them
would have hated Martin Luther King if
they had been around at this
time there's just no question about that
and to Pence's comment I guess it's true
in the sense that Martin Luther King
inspired people to change for the better
and Donald Trump has inspired people to
change for the worse by galvanizing and
activating the white nationalists and
the white supremacists and the alt-right
and all these horrible elements of
society this is the second man in line
for the presidency and he's at least
claiming off of a quote he read off of a
piece of paper that was off to his left
there at least that he believes Donald
Trump is like Martin Luther King and the
the comparison could just not be more
ridiculous a man who fought racism
compared to a man who has reinvigorated
more racism than any recent president I
guess other than Obama merely by virtue
of being black which really did agitate
the racists but that's sort of a
different story and I don't know what's
more outrageous pence saying that Trump
is like Martin Luther King or Trump
saying that he believes himself to be
sort of like Abraham Lincoln both are
crazy and in the interests of trying to
find some silver lining here or some
other way that maybe this could be true
I sort of found one path which is that
Martin Luther King inspired people to
make changes to improve this country
it's possible that by being president
Donald Trump will inspire people to not
only vote him out but also to make sure
that nothing like this atrocity of a
presidency ever happens again and maybe
that would be the one way that both
could have inspired positive change well
that's certainly a stretch but less of a
stretch than Mike Pence's example was I
hate when Republicans go on and on about
how Martin Luther King would be a
Republican if he was living today like
the guy died fifty years ago we were in
such a different political time then
it's really hard to say what his
politics would be like but given the
fact that Martin Luther King praised
democratic socialism on many accounts I
think he would have more a lot in line
with say Alexandria Bukowski or Cortes
or Bernie Sanders than he would with
Donald Trump and Mike Pence yeah it's
very hard to a man
that in 2019 Martin Luther King jr. says
Trump Pence
that's who I'm voting for
extraordinarily difficult to imagine
that and seriously do you think that
this is delusion do you think this is
compulsive lying is it trolling is it
just being bad people or trying to come
up with interesting things to say on TV
I really don't know which it is it might
just be malignant ignorant in the end
he's just trying to be a savvy
politician tie in the holiday with his
agenda at the moment that's all Mike
Pence is trying to do here would have
been much more credible feeling if he
didn't have to look down at that piece
of paper to read the quote but I guess
nobody's perfect right